well the Democrats on the house tell
gence committee have unearthed enough
evidence in my opinion to justify about
three or four articles of impeachment
against the president I'm Nick Gillespie
for reason and I am sitting down on the
studio floor of Liberty file with Judge
Napolitano with Judge Andrew Napolitano
he's the senior judicial analyst at Fox
News Channel judge we're gonna talk
about impeachment and the Constitution
pleasure to make you look very good in
my chair I don't know how well I look in
the guest chair okay well no and now the
Hunter has become the hunted Oh only you
can put it you are
one of the most outspoken libertarian
defenders of constitutional government
of limiting the executive branch as well
as the government altogether what is the
case that Donald Trump has committed
impeachable offenses well the Democrats
on the House gence Committee have
unearthed enough evidence in my opinion
to justify about three or four articles
of impeachment against the president we
have to start this conversation but
underscoring the fact that impeachment
is not legal it is political right it's
only constitutional basis treason
bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors one of their counts as
bribery which I'll explain in a minute
and but that other high crimes and
misdemeanors doesn't that kind of open
it up yes what I I know you've quoted
him at length but Gerald Ford as a
congressman in the early 70s yes where
he was vice president before Watergate
yes okay he said you know in an
impeachable offenses whatever Congress
decide the house decides on a given deck
and he made that statement based on a
phrase and the Constitution which says
the House of Representatives shall have
the sole Sol E power of impeachment and
another phrase in the Constitution which
says each house shall write its own
rules so those rules don't even have to
be fair as long as they generate the
support of the majority right the rules
under which the current house is
operating were written in January 2015
when the speaker was John Boehner and
the majority was Republican so that
means the Republicans are going to be
screaming bloody murder about his rules
are completely illegitimate we're to
howl did shifty
you have come up with these and all of
that congressman Schiff what do you like
him or not whether you agree with him or
not it's following rules that the
Republicans authored four years for five
years what are those three or four
articles because when you go into
impeachment the you know and I'm trying
to channel this from 20 years ago right
when when they'll close when now wait a
minute know who were a baby 20 years ago
that is true but I was precocious right
here's what I think we had basic cable
in the womb here's what I think the
Democrats will want Nick here's what I
think they won't they will advance one
is bribery the allegation is the
technical definition of bribery is the
failure to perform an official duty
until a thing of value comes your way
and they will argue that the president's
failure to disperse funds that the
Congress ordered be dispersed
until the recipient of the funds agreed
to investigate a potential political
opponent is an act of bribery that is
enough in my opinion to make it over the
threshold of impeachable offenses I
don't think it's enough to convict of
bribery but it's enough to allege it for
the purpose of impeachment the second
charge will be high crimes and
misdemeanors
election law violation the third crime
will be obstruction of justice the
fourth will be interference with a
witness and the fifth may be lying under
oath take that last one there are
reports based upon a letter that the
general counsel of the House of
Representatives wrote to the United
States Court of Appeals for the District
of Columbia Circuit when in seeking
copies of the grand jury materials in
the Muller investigation and asked why
he responded because we believe the
president lied under oath and the
intelligence committee which is
investigating impeachment needs this the
alleged lie under oath was the
president's statement to Bob Muller that
he doesn't recall a conversation on the
phone with Roger stone over whether or
not stone had access to the WikiLeaks
material that's been established in the
in the stone trial so now the Democrats
are interested in pursuing it so the
other two articles of impeachment will
be election law vile
nation the election laws for better for
worse I think this is a horrible law
because it interferes with free speech
but it is the law
asking a foreign government the phrase
in the statute is soliciting for
assistance for a campaign is a criminal
act whether the foreign government
provides what you asked for or not but
wait if can't Trump just say or I guess
what I'm gonna ask you is you know what
is the Republican response or what is
sketch up the president's defense okay
I'll say what are you talking about I'm
investigating you know in 2017 Politico
and a host of other publications said
Ukraine was trying to influence the
American election 2016 Trump is just
saying I'm trying to get to the bottom
of this that that eruption that is his
defense I've actually looked in the
camera and said you would be better off
acknowledging the facts but arguing that
none of this is impeachable because
you're going to lose on the facts one of
the reasons he used Rudy Giuliani as the
emissary for this information is because
of his and Rudy's belief in the
attorney-client privilege meaning Rudy
had never been interrogated and forced
to divulge what he said to the president
the president said to him guess what
there's no attorney-client privilege in
an impeachment proceeding that's why
Rudy and I say some scandal that's way
through it didn't honor the the subpoena
that was served on him the last article
of impeachment that I believe they're
contemplating it's the same one with
which they charged a President Nixon and
President Clinton and that is
obstruction of Congress by refusing to
permit officials of the executive branch
to testify and refusing to permit those
officials to have access to their own
documents the most poignant example of
which was earlier this week when
ambassador Sandland Gordon Sandlin
testified they won't give me my own
phone records and my own notes because
the president has told them not to write
is that is that a legit you know or is
this also you know obviously the the
branches of government are in tension
with one another right and is a lot of
this to go back to that idea this is a
political proceeding not a legal one
is this just a flex by Congress to say
you know what we have particularly the
house we've hated Trump we've wanted to
unseat him from the beginning no
question now we we can do it and we
don't all we have to do is get a
majority of members of Congress that's
you blame that on James Madison not on
Adam Schiff that's the that's the
Constitution that's the that's the
procedure that said if I like to think
of him as mr. Dolly Madison that's the
real legacy is the sweets and ice cream
it's all delicious backed up but but
it's actually three James Madison's the
same person but three radical different
thoughts the third of which is the small
government libertarian but not the first
to but but back to to the Constitution
because the house can write its own
rules and because those rules say that a
committee has subpoena power you need
the authority of the full house and
because there are no defenses except
those which come from the Constitution
the president cannot interfere with the
investigation of himself without risking
this chakra so when Clinton said to
betty curry his secretary don't tell
them and when Nixon said to her
Ehrlichman Haldeman and Dean don't tell
them and some of them did they were
still charged with this because the
obstruction doesn't have to succeed
right only from from the presidential
perspective it only has to be
articulated so this is at least the
Democratic argument how do you feel
about this in in a in any other context
virtually in any other kind of legal
proceeding and again this is a political
proceeding it's not a legal one but you
would be on the side of saying you know
what the police or the investigating
force should be held to the strictest
standard of behavior and you know the
FBI and you've talked about the you know
the FBI you know we'll talk to you for
hours so that you make misstatements and
then they can charge you with lying to
the FBI or a structure is not this is
why you should never talk to the FBI
even if you're on the right so I mean
isn't something similar going on here
and does that risk taking you know what
is effectively a political dispute
you're asking me if this is just from a
moral perspective or if it's
Constitution
yeah it's absolutely constitutional it
is probably unjust from a moral
perspective for the reasons you've
articulated the president gets no due
process but he's not entitled to due
process under the Constitution until
this gets done a Senate if it gets there
and that's when there's a trial in the
traditional sense except that the jury
is the members of the Senate so what is
the essential difference I mean
impeachment you you only bring articles
of impeachment if you think the
president deserves to be removed from
office right theoretically I mean if
you're if you're on the team that is
pushing impeachment well listen if you
push impeachment without a national
consensus behind it you'll suffer at the
polls right I mean the the remedy for an
inappropriate impeachment is not
stonewalling it's getting your opponents
driven from office as bill clinton
succeeded in with all of his impeachment
prosecutors except for one who was the
one who didn't then the ground were
spent and now senator graham correct the
others were all kicked out what one of
them works for another network and has
the morning show and the show rhymes
with morning shows I'm not using on that
net on that network are so loud to say
can I say that why main west Congressman
Scarborough run-time Congressman Jim
Rogan who's now a Superior Court judge
in California and was defeated for
re-election by Adam Schiff so connect
that yet again this is just kind of like
you know next we're gonna be talking
about an oasis reunion and Snapple
coming right this is the 90s being
redone right
well it's nostalgia there's a lot of
people who keep popping up in these in
these events so is is an impeachment
just from the moral perspective probably
not not in this case I mean it's right
because you're right but as a Jew during
the Nixon Nixon I mean he resigned
before he was officially impeach but he
should have been impeached and he's
probably almost certainly should have
been well and Nixon is the extreme case
even though it was the cover-up of a
two-bit break-in
Nixon's statement that if the witch is
made after he left office to David Frost
if the president does it it's not
illegal I mean that statement shows an
attitude about the presidency that the
president can do no wrong right and now
do you think Nixon's impeachment was led
by Peter Rodino for whom I was a page in
the House of Representatives where
Dina's mind was absolutely made up
before the first witness testified and
where did Regina get all of his evidence
from a secret grand jury proceeding run
by Leon Jaworski mm-hmm where did Henry
Hyde get all of his evidence from he was
the chair of the Judiciary Committee
when Clinton was impeached a secret
grand jury run by Ken Starr so so
secrecy is often the birth of this
material the politicians often decide
ahead of time where it's going to go
they just have to make their case to
their colleagues and to the so do you
think that you've said that you know
Trump should be impeached
should he be removed from office based
on what you've seen now I can't imagine
that he will be removed from off because
the the Senate is run by the Republicans
and you need 2/3 of the Senate yes but
that's just doing math do you think you
know in the interests of the country in
the and not not of like you know making
us feel good about each other but has he
overstepped the bounds that the
executive branch should you know be held
to you know he hasn't presented a
defense and I don't know if he if he
plans to the evidence of his impeachable
behavior at this point in my view was
overwhelming but being an ex judge of
being a lawyer I have to withhold
judgment until a defense is presented
now the defense would have to come out
of the mouth I would think of people
who've refused to testify vice president
Pence secretary of state Pompeo acting
chief of staff Mulvaney and the
president of Safa the president is
teasing everybody was saying he might
testify you know so forth things are
however fractious they might be they're
proceeding along the the way that the
Constitution maps them out are we in a
constitutional crisis or when do we get
to a constitutional I don't think we're
in a constitutional crisis we would get
to one
if the president were removed from
office and refused to leave I mean that
would be a constitutional crisis
you could argue there's a mini
constitutional crisis when the house
demands something and the White House
refuses to present it that's why we have
judiciary now neither side wants to go
to the judiciary because both sides want
this over with right so they can get
into the 20/20 political season so I
don't think we're at that crisis level
we're gonna clash but not a crisis what
so that'll come if that if it this goes
to the judiciary and then one of the
sides refuses to abide by what well
their court says you know Nixon famously
refused to surrender the tapes went to
the Supreme Court's unanimous opinion
United States versus Nixon which ordered
the tapes surrendered then he resigned
and we all know how that happened
so if the court were to order President
Trump to surrender documents and he were
to refuse well that would be a
constitutional crisis I happen to think
if the court ordered something and the
Supreme Court either didn't hear the
appeal or affirmed that decision I think
he would comply because he would begin
to lose his base if he thumbed his nose
at the judiciary I know he criticizes
the judicial right says there Obama
judges and Bush judges and Trump judges
I don't think that washes in this
environment how do you think more
broadly how is President Trump doing as
a chief executive is he do you feel like
he's furthering the interests of the
country do you feel he is doing damage
to if not the the law but the traditions
and customs of the executive branch
because it does seem like you know a lot
of the criticism of Trump is less about
the substance and it's more about the
style you know it doesn't calm this
morning at foxnews.com
and elsewhere argues that no American
president in the post Woodrow Wilson era
has stayed within the confines of the
Constitution and each president has more
authority than his predecessors for the
simple reason that Democratic Congress
has give power to Democratic presidents
Republican Congress's I can give you
many examples of this give power to
Republican presidents and that power
stays in the
and see so Donald Trump actually has
more authority than Barack Obama did who
had more authority than george w bush
did etc what are you not that type of
authority to do things outside the
confines of the constitution like use a
drone to kill somebody in a foreign
country really rankles my libertarian
values that is far afield from the
government that madison Dali's husband
virginia where you want to refer to him
gave us so do you how do you how do you
pull this back how do you how do you
know and obviously you've written a
number of books but you know many times
you can't can you pull it back there
short of a revolution or short of
secession i'm not talking about the
south seceding i'm talking about i'm
sure if california wanted to leave and
the republicans ran congress even though
the IRS would lose a lot of money they
basically say go it's going to take
something like that to turn this around
because all the power keeps going in the
same direction away from individuals
away from municipalities away from the
states and towards the federal
government i mean i have argued that the
federal government stays in power by an
act of bribery it bribes the states with
cash a bribes the rich with bailouts it
bribes the middle class with tax cuts it
bribes the poor with welfare and as long
as it can keep doing that bribing it's
going to stay in power it doesn't matter
which which party is in power the
mindset is the same the the donald trump
that criticized barack obama has killed
more people with drones than barack
obama did the barack obama who
criticized george w bush killed more
people with drones than george w bush
did i could keep going on down to wilson
would you agree you know theoretically
that every if a president should be
impeached when they exceed the powers a
lot of to the executive branch from the
constitution right everybody so
everybody after wilson would have been
impeached right i think you have to add
to that when there's a perception in the
land a strong consensus that this has
happened i don't believe that that
consensus exists today
which is why mrs. pelosi and congressman
Schiff are run a risky venture who's
they will have to confront the voters
whatever the outcome it is part of you
proud as an italian-american that you
know Nancy Pelosi Rudy Giuliani you know
that this is you know it's a lot of
Italian Americans in the mixer know can
I reveal to the people watching us now
that even though your name is Gillespie
you are half Italian yeah the better
half Italian let's not go there
yeah but what I mean
what short of revolution I mean you
write books you appear on TV you write
columns you know we talk about is is
part of this an education process to say
look you know we're going to get the
government I mean we we can make changes
at the polls right like what I have
argued that it doesn't matter what ELISA
Ron Paul or another Bernie Sanders let's
take two people that are really
different
we're president I don't think it matters
because they are basically bound by the
laws tempted by all the authority the
president has reinforced by generations
of exceeding the bounds of the
Constitution it would take a real
serious ideologue in Bernie's case
somebody that wants to destroy the
capitalist system and redistribute
wealth in Ron Paul's case somebody wants
to shrink the government down to the
size it was when Little Jimmy Madison
wrote Thea wrote the Constitution short
of that the people that are always in
power now called the deep state the the
bankers the diplomats the bureaucrats
will still have those great levers of
power no matter who is in the White
House short of these extremes so you're
a systems man I mean so even if Bernie
Sanders or Ron Paul were elected they
would be more expansive than they were
going here no I don't think so I can't
speak for Bernie Sanders but I know Ron
Paul very well and he is absolutely
faithful to the small government
principles that that government is best
which governs least
having I don't think he would he would
move this is prediction now yeah I mean
it's
I don't think if he became president he
would be tempted to be a president like
george w bush or or donald trump is
there something in the 21st century that
is accelerating the expansion of federal
power because you know the one thing you
can say about I mean like Bush Obama and
now Trump or actually and I personally I
don't think Trump has been as expansive
in most ways as bush or Obama partly
because he doesn't articulate any
rationale hidden or otherwise for what
let me tell you what he's done hidden or
otherwise which is to borrow a trillion
dollars a year right and that of course
well one day consume us you know when
there's so much debt that it can't be
paid people will either stop working or
stop paying taxes and then the
government the government collapses so
the acceleration of debt in the 21st
century will be the ruination of the
federal government this is not the first
time that a mighty vast country or
empire falters not because of external
enemies but because of debt essentially
correct correct
it also falters like the Roman Republic
collapsed when they gave dictatorial
powers to a general named lumpy to fight
off pirates that were destroying it now
you fought off the Pirates and won the
wars and kept all that power and a
generation later there was no Republic
there's a dictator you think that that
happened with the Patriot Act which and
this I guess is another question for you
as we're talking about all eyes are
focused on impeachment you know various
parts of the Patriot Act or being you
know lengthened again or renewed again
is this all a distraction ultimately
from what really matters which are the
you know actual limitations on the
ability of the federal government to spy
on people to extract money to extract
compliance I don't think the federal
government recognizes its own limits and
the courts have looked the other way I
mean my problem with justice than judge
Kavanaugh is this I'm holding up my
iphone what's in here personal intimate
political legal medical and in his world
you don't need a search want to get in
there the government can just go in
there
where does that come from the Patriot
Act the most unpatriotic abominable
piece of legislation in history since
the Alien and Sedition Acts of 1796 but
do you see any you know I don't know you
know five six years ago people were
talking about politicians like Rand Paul
Thomas Massie Justin Amash in particular
it's a kind of vanguard of a libertarian
they were all small-l libertarian they
were all in the Republican Party and
obviously now an independent what
happened to that kind of boomlet of
interest in people who were
constitutionally driven and we're
talking about restricting federal power
but you know what's going on with that I
mean Justin Amash and Thomas Massie are
faithful to small government principles
Senator Paul has seen fit to work with
the White House in order to achieve
certain goals and be charitable here
let's just say my voting record would be
far closer to congressman Amash and
Congressman nasty than to Senator Paul
but I understand what it's like being a
Republican in the majority in the Senate
today they have a senator from your
state is the majority leader be very
difficult not to play ball wait does
state what specifically has Rand Paul
again other than kind of certain
statements of sport what has he what has
he done that you think contravenes a
kind of articulated you know I would
have to look at his voting record but
there are many many issues in the Senate
where the Republicans vote as one voice
and there should be a small government
dissent example justice Kavanagh this is
a perfect example for the small
government Republicans in the Senate
which as far as I know it was just two
of them Mike Lee and Rand Paul to make a
stand for the Fourth Amendment instead
they voted to confirm somebody who will
ratify legislation that permits them to
be spied on Justice Scalia told me that
the court was being spied on under the
Patriot Act
so you
not a Cavanaugh fan at all you think I'm
not picking on him socially yeah but I'm
not a fan of any big government person
justice course which is a different
story
I know justice course such as brain we
studied jurisprudence under the same
person a generation apart but the same
Ginsburg no no John finis f I have an
eye a so-so Australian a professor who
taught at Oxford when corset was there
in it and Notre Dame when I was there
finis we chose sourcing the Constitution
to Australian it's no wonder we're and
so yeah thinness teaches that our rights
come from our humanity natural law
theory Justice Thomas accepts natural
law theory nobody else on the bench does
in the absence of natural law theory
that our rights come from our humanity
as Jefferson wrote in the Declaration of
Independence then our rights come from
the government and the government that
gives them can take them away that's the
view that almost everybody in the
government accepts that is absolutely
contrary to first principles that Rand
Paul should be fighting for
here's a question there we're taping
this on I don't know what Thursday I
guess and there was a democratic debate
tonight before the Democratic candidates
do any of them strike you as
particularly good in terms of being
bound by the Constitution being sworn by
constitutional limits absolutely not
having said that there juice there does
seem to be a number of developments that
are very consistent with a libertarian
worldview we're talking about things
like winding down many aspects if not
the whole shebang of the war on drugs
criminal justice reform which Donald
Trump has signed you know has moved
through the government that we seem to
be on some level retreating from the
world stage as a military power all
those things I support yeah are you
there unfortunately they're being done
in baby steps but maybe that's the
political reality than the president's
do the movie steps but I support as you
know withdrawing from the from the world
stage I certainly support the right of
adults to put whatever they want in
their own bodies so those things are in
the right direction that has happened by
the federal government looking the other
way while state governments have
permitted the use of certain
recreational drugs I think marijuana is
the only one
right now yeah there I mean there's a
couple of budding cities and why not
doing things like magic mushrooms and
whatnot but that's still down the road
to come are you a drug user at all have
you ever smoked weed no no no to both
questions I'm terrified I'm a health
fanatic right I'm terrified of putting
electrons atoms right to keep it in the
dishes real name as you know was Angelo
city how you absolutely know very few
people will know that I am NOT like
Charles doing that dynamic tension what
I seven second where I do work out quite
regularly are you optimistic you know or
let me put it this way because I think I
know the answer to that but given you
know the way the kind of decline tale
that you've told that you know since
Madison you know things have just been
going up to pot ever since but are you
optimistic about the future of the
country I am NOT okay I am NOT I think
power will continue to grow the federal
government will continue to absorb debt
it will continue to bribe people to stay
in existence and eventually will fall
like an overripe apple but do you feel
like you're freer now to live your life
however you want today as opposed to 30
years ago or 40 years ago and when I
asked that not based on the size of
government but by the the whole offering
of what you can do with your life and
that includes technology it includes the
decline of certain types of cultural
gatekeepers that said now or social well
as well as I know the decline of
cultural gatekeepers about certain
lifestyles obviously is liberating but
the same technology which lets me put
the works of Thomas Aquinas in my pocket
also lets the government follow me
wherever I go and record whatever
conversation I have with Gillespie or
whoever I'm talking to the Constitution
be damned damned that's the federal
attitude about it they could get rid of
the Patriot Act the NSA would still be
spying us they could spy on the
president and he would still authorize
spying on everybody else you know what
on that upbeat note I think we're gonna
end it we've been talking with Judge
Andrew Napolitano he's the senior
judicial analyst at Fox News Channel
author of many books including several
bestsellers a regular contributor Fox
news.com judge thanks for talking you're
welcome for a reason I'm Nick Gillespie